we're going to fight back
right it has everything to do with
basically just killing 8 million Jews
and then moving on to the rest of the
West how do I know that well when people
tell you something you should listen so
here is a free Palestine crowd in Boston
which is a it's a pro Hamas these are
people are pro Hamas remember there's
nobody out there going you know guys
Hamas is a bit much we're not thrilled
with the Israelis but okay uh but yeah
they're not just chanting about uh
Israel they're coming for America too
Boston Massachusetts the United States
biggest threat in the world today isra
the USA so when they try to isolate the
Palestinian resistance and vilify it
what are we going to do we're going to
fight back
right so that's right outside Harvard
did you catch what they were saying
biggest threat in the world today Israel
and the USA so again you don't I think
it's a I think it's a mistaken worldview
but I can accept the worldview of
someone who's a total isolation
and who who doesn't want foreign aid to
anyone and who wants America to have no
role in the world like I can
intellectually I can accept that I don't
think that makes you a bad person right
I think maybe you're a little mistaken
in in how sort of real politic or the
real world operates um but if you think
that they're not coming for the rest of
the West next right Israel is just the
front line of this thing and then what
do you do you think again I'll I'll just
keep saying it until more and more
people get it they could take out Israel
take out those 8 million Jews they're
going to have to kill about 2 million
Muslims who live there peacefully too
and beduins and everything else the only
place in the Middle East that is
anything like coexistence etc etc where
minorities are treated fair and people
actually vote for their leaders and
everything but do you think they will
wrap it up and go home after no they
will just start moving on and again who
do you think is more indigenous to the
land Israel Jews to the ancient land of
Israel or those people uh chanting with
Hamas flags and they're Hamas Flags
they're not pal inian Flags there is
there's no differentiation because none
of them are making differentiation so I
don't think I have to who do you think
is more indigenous to the land like you
got
it